[Music]
what is
going to be
the future of learning
i do have a plan
but in order for me to tell you what the
plan is
um i need to tell you a little story
which kind of sets the stage
i tried to look at
where did
the kind of learning we do in schools
where did it come from
and you know you can look far back into
the past but if you look at present day
schooling the way it is
it's quite easy to figure out
where it came from
it came from about
300 years ago
and it came from the last and the
biggest of the empires on this planet
imagine trying to run the show
trying to run the entire planet
without computers
without telephones
with data
hand written on pieces of paper
and traveling by ships
but the victorians actually did it what
they did was
amazing
they created a global computer
made up of people
it's still with us today it's called the
bureaucratic administrative machine
in order to have that machine running
you need lots and lots of people
they made another machine
to produce those people
the school
the schools would produce the people
who would then
become parts of the
bureaucratic administrative machine
they must be
identical to each other
they must know three things they must
have good handwriting because the data
is handwritten
they must be able to read
and they must be able to do
multiplication division addition and
subtraction in their head
they must be so identical that you could
pick one up from new zealand
and ship them to canada
and he would be
instantly functional
the victorians were great engineers
they engineered a system that was so
robust
that is still with us today
continuously producing
identical people
for a machine
that no longer exists
the empire is gone
so what are we doing
with that design that produces these
identical people
and
what are we going to do next
if we ever are going to do anything else
with it
so that's a pretty strong comment there
i said schools as we know them now
they're obsolete i'm not saying they're
broken it's quite fashionable to say
that the education system is broken it's
not broken it's wonderfully constructed
it's just that we don't need it anymore
it's outdated
what's the kind of jobs that we have
today well the clerks are the computers
they're there in thousands in every
office
and you have people who guide those
computers to do their clerical jobs
those people don't need to be able to
write beautifully by hand
they don't need to be able to multiply
numbers in their heads
they do need to be able to read
in fact they need to be able to read
discerningly
but that's today but we don't even know
what the jobs of the future are going to
look like
we know that people will work from
wherever they want whenever they want in
whatever way they want
how is present-day schooling going to
prepare them for that world
well i bumped into this whole thing
completely by accident
i used to teach people how to write
computer programs in new delhi 14 years
ago
and
right next to where i used to work there
was a slum
and i used to think how how on earth are
those kids ever going to learn to write
computer programs or are they should
they not
at the same time we also had lots of
parents
rich people who had computers
and who used to tell me you know my son
um i think he's gifted
because you know he does wonderful
things with computers and my daughter oh
surely she's you know extra intelligent
and so on so suddenly figured that how
come all the rich people are having
these extraordinary gifted children
what did the poor do wrong
i made a hole in the in the boundary
wall of the slum next to my office i
stuck a computer inside it just to see
what would happen if i gave a computer
to children who never would have won
didn't know any english didn't know what
the internet was the children came
running in it was three feet off the
ground and they said what is this and i
said yeah but it's you know i don't know
so
they said um why have you put it there i
said just like that and they said can we
touch it i said if you wish to and i
went away
about eight hours later we found them
browsing
and teaching each other how to browse so
i said but that's impossible
because you know how is it possible
they don't know anything my colleague
said no it's a simple solution
one of your students must have been
passing by showed them how to use the
mouse
so i said yeah that's possible so i
repeated the experiment i went 300 miles
out of delhi into a really remote
village where the chances of a you know
a passing software development engineer
it was very little
i repeated the experiment there there
was no place to stay so i stuck my
computer in i went away came back after
a couple of months found kids playing
games on it when they saw me they said
we want a faster processor and a better
mouse
so
i said how on earth do you know all this
and they said something very interesting
to me
in a irritated voice they said you've
given us a machine that works only in
english so we had to teach ourselves
english in order to use it
[Applause]
i
that's the first time as a teacher that
i heard the word
teach ourselves said so casually
here's a short glimpse from those years
that's the first day at the hole in the
wall on your right is an eight-year-old
um
to his left
is his uh student
um she is six
and uh he's teaching her how to browse
then on to the uh you know other parts
of the country i repeated this over and
over again
getting exactly the same results
everywhere
[Music]
an eight-year-old telling his elder
sister what to do
and finally a girl
explaining in marathi
what it is and said there's a processor
inside
i started publishing
i published everywhere i wrote down i
measured everything and i said in nine
months a group of children left alone
with a computer in any language would
reach the same standard as an office
secretary in the west i'd seen it happen
over and over and over again
but i was curious to know what else
would they do if they could do this much
if i started experimenting with other
subjects
among them for example pronunciation
there's one community of children in
southern india whose english
pronunciation was really bad
and they needed good pronunciation
because that would improve their jobs
i gave them a speech to text engine in a
computer and i said keep talking into it
until it types what you say
okay
they did that
and watched a little bit of
this to meet you
nice to meet you
the the reason i ended with that the
face of this young lady over there is
because uh i suspect many of you know
her she's now
joined a call center in hyderabad
and may have tortured you about your
credit card bills
you know in a very clear english accent
so then
people said well how far will it go
where does it stop i decided i would i
would destroy my own argument by
creating an absurd proposition
i made a hypothesis
a ridiculous hypothesis tamil is a south
indian language and i said can tamil
speaking children in the south indian
village
learn the biotechnology of dna
replication and english from a street
side computer
and i said i'll measure them they'll get
a zero
i'll spend a couple of months i'll leave
it for a couple of months i'll go back
they'll get another zero
i'll go back to the lab and say we need
teachers
i found a village it was called kali
kupam in southern india
i put in hole in the world computers
there downloaded all kinds of stuff from
the internet about dna replication
most of which i didn't understand
the children came rushing us what's all
this so i said um
it's very topical very important it's
all in english
so they said how can we understand such
big english words and you know diagrams
and chemistry
so by now i had developed a new
pedagogical method so i applied that i
said i haven't the foggiest idea
and anyway i'm going away
so i
i left them for a couple of months they
had got a zero i gave them a test
i came back after two months and the
children trooped in and said we've
understood nothing
so i said i mean what did i expect
so i said okay but
how long did it take you before you
decided that you can't understand
anything
so they said we haven't given up
we look at it every single day
so i said what you don't understand
these screens and you keep staring at it
for two months what for
so a little girl
who you'll see just now she raised her
hand and she says to me in broken tamil
in english she said well apart from the
fact that improper replication of the
dna molecule causes disease we haven't
understood anything else
[Applause]
i tested them
i got an educational impossibility zero
to thirty percent in two months in the
tropical heat under with a computer
under the tree in a language that they
didn't know doing something that's a
decade ahead of their time
absurd but
but
i had to follow the victorian norm 30 is
a fail
how do i get them to pass i have to get
them 20 more marks i couldn't find a
teacher what i did find was a friend
that they had
a 22 year old girl who was an accountant
and she played with them all the time so
i asked this girl can you help them
so she says absolutely not
i i didn't i didn't have science in
school i have no idea what they're doing
under that tree all day long i
i can't help you
i said um i'll tell you what use the
method of the grandmother so she says
what's that so stand behind them
whenever they do anything you just say
well wow i mean how did you do that
what's the next page gosh when i was
your age i could have never done that i
mean you know what grannies do
so
she did that for two more months the
scores jumped to 50 percent
kali kupam had caught up with my control
school in new delhi a rich private
school with a trained biotechnology
teacher when i saw that graph i knew
there is a way to level the playing
field
i got the camera angle wrong in that
that one is just amateur stuff but what
she was saying
as you could make out was about neurons
but her hands were like that and she was
saying neurons communicate
at 12.
so
what are jobs going to be like well we
know what they're like today
what's learning going to be like we know
what it's like today children pouring
over with their mobile phones on the one
hand and then reluctantly going to
school to to pick up their books with
the other hand
what will it be tomorrow
could it be
that we don't need to go to school at
all
could it be that at the point in time
when you need to know something
you can find out
in two minutes
could it be
a devastating question
a question that was framed for me by
nicolas negroponte could it be that we
are heading towards or maybe in a future
where knowing is obsolete but that's
terrible we are homo sapiens
knowing that's that's that's what
distinguishes us from the apes
but look at it this way
it took nature 100 million years
to make the apes stand up
and become homo sapiens it took us only
10 000 to make knowing obsolete
what an achievement that is
but we have to integrate that
into our own future
encouragement seems to be the key
if you look at cook pump if you look at
all of the experiments that i did
it was simply
saying wow
saluting learning
there is evidence from neuroscience
the reptilian part of our brain which
sits in the center of our brain
when it's threatened it shuts down
everything else it shuts down the
prefrontal cortex the parts which learn
it shuts all of that down
punishment and examinations are seen as
threats
we take our children
we make them shut their brains down and
then we say perform
why did they create a system like that
because it was needed
there was an age in the age of empires
when you needed those people
who can survive under threat
when you're standing in a trench all
alone
if you could have survived you're okay
you passed
if you didn't you failed
but the age of empires is gone
what happens to creativity in our age
we need to shift that balance back
from threat
to pleasure i came back to england
looking for british grandmothers
i put out notices in paper saying if
you're a british grandmother if you have
broadband and a web camera can you give
me one hour of your time per week for
free i got 200 in the first two weeks i
know more british grandmothers than
anyone in the universe
they're called the granny cloud
the granny cloud sits on the internet if
there's a child in in trouble we beam a
gran
she goes
she goes on over skype and she sorts
things out i've seen them do it from a
village called diggles
in northwestern england
deep inside a village in tamil nadu
india
six thousand miles away
she does it with only one age-old
gesture
okay
watch this
you can't catch me
you say it
i'm the gingerbread man
well done very good
so what's happening here
i think what we need to look at is we
need to look at learning
as the product of educational
self-organization if you allow the
educational process to self-organize
then learning emerges it's not about
making learning happen it's about
letting it happen
the teacher sets
the process in motion and then she
stands back in awe
and watches as learning happens i think
that's what all this is pointing at
but how will we know how will we come to
know
but i intend to build these
self-organized learning environments
they are basically
broadband collaboration and
encouragement put together i've tried
this in many many schools that's been
tried all over the world and teachers
sort of
stand back and say it just happens by
itself and i said yeah it happens by
itself how did you know that and i said
you won't believe the children who told
me and where they're from
here's a soul in action
this one is in england
uh he maintains law and order
because remember there's no teacher
on alpine is equal to the number of
protons in the fire minus the number of
electrons
a decade ahead of a time
so souls i think we need a curriculum of
big questions you already heard about
that you know what what that means there
was a time when stone age men and women
you sit and look up at the sky and say
what are those twinkling lights
they built the first curriculum but
we've lost sight of that wondrous
questions we've brought it down to the
tangent of an angle
but that's not
that's not sexy enough
the way you would put it to a
nine-year-old is to say if a meteorite
was coming to hit the earth
how would you figure out if it was going
to or not
and if he says well
what how you say there's a magic word
it's called the tangent of an angle and
leave him alone he'll figure it out
so here are a couple of images from
souls
i've tried incredible
incredible questions
when did the world begin
how will it end
to nine year olds
this one's about what happens to the air
we breathe
this is done by children
without the help
of any teacher the teacher only raises
the question
and then stands back
and admires the answer
so
what's my wish
my wish is
that we design the future of learning
we don't want to be spare parts for a
great human computer do we
so we need to design
a future for learning
and i've got to hang on i've got to get
this wording exactly right
because you know it's very important
my wish is to help design a future of
learning by supporting children all over
the world to tap into their wonder and
their ability to work together
help me build this school it will be
called a school in the cloud
it will be a school
where children go on these intellectual
adventures driven by the big questions
which their mediators put in
the way i want to do this
is to build a facility
where i can study this
it's a facility which is practically
unmanned there's only one granny
who who manages health and safety the
rest of it's from the cloud the lights
are turned on and off by the cloud etc
etc everything's done from the cloud
but i want you for another purpose
you can do self-organized learning
environments at home
in the school
outside of school in clubs it's very
easy to do there's a great document
produced by ted which tells you how to
do it
if you would please please do it
across all five continents
and send me the data
then i'll put it all together
move it into the school of clouds
and create the future of learning
that's my wish
and just one last thing i'll take you to
the top of the himalayas
at 12 000 feet
where the air is thin
and once built two hole in the wall
computers the children flocked there
there was this little girl who's
following me around
and i said to her you know i want to i
want to give a computer to everybody
every child i don't know what should i
do
and i was trying to take a picture of
her you know quietly she suddenly raised
a hand like this
and said to me
get on with it
i think it was good advice i'll follow
her advice i'll stop talking thank you
thank you very much